it's a fool a Capcom exclusive
we got the homie Vic represent kids
these days Trap House rocking stores
right now man he's lead MC in the group
any could sing too if you guys listen to
who do you love on the album attempt
singing not some white guy yeah yeah
yeah turn it up in my phone's a little
bit
yo yo yo yo shots out yeah shot down in
a building understand me yo yo yo
southside shot down educated polish
teacher investigated graveyard JSL
designated moves some real ish you don't
want to test them on a freestyle cuz i
kill this um you could fill it in a
second it's all for the top yo every
time that i be wrecking like my man
recognize you better recognize you get
second down you the second size i'm the
first model with your lady she's a
hottie she said she want to come back
and get me that body i'm scottie pippen
when i'm different in the range you can
check me listening in the ring bumping
shot to come when i'm riding
most of these cats they be the second
you know that i'm divided on it's a
scary world i'm blunt flicking like did
he's jheri curl on the wall when the
fall class she can't pass it my boy keep
it lit don't ask him you can't add [ __ ]
I got it on deck that's if a question if
you want that I rip I'm if I'm in the
session shouts to the kids in the van
many cooling wit mister I love college
but no schooling I never did it myself
you know that I be fooling never broke
the rule but sure it's the ruling of
I'm rolling with it vic mensa nick tesla
wish we had from some free Electric City
for New York City cuz the hurricane
shandi's no joke though so I want to
show some piece of love for everybody on
the East Coast coaster coaster social oh
so you know I still cheap like Sammy
Sosa when I come through I still got
about his beats like Chuck doing the
kitchen when I burn up these egg beats
these egg whites you don't eat them I
need the cholesterol from the yellow
ones dog cuz I was in the hospital just
today I was like this is crazy how
amazing the human body is it's so
fragile but so resilient at the same
time yesterday I was fine now I'm
watching the time get it straight
I'm like raise my blood is my heart is
barely pumping I'm like man I gotta do
something so what did I do
I went down the street to club red and
had some phone my friends instead
because I was like Mary's life is worth
it man it isn't perfect but I'll make it
worth it like this versus the Freestyle
booth Vic and my man shut English yeah
that's what it is man it's not perfect
but it's worth it
these record labels try to teach us like
we were flesh that's why I taught him I
didn't do the school route I had to hop
up on the mic so I could cool out
stepped up on the stage I know that they
appreciate cuz every time that I Spit
you know the rhyme alleviate take the
weight off your shoulders heavier than a
boat about to take it out to Boulder
Colorado told you smoking on the soldier
like I'm the boy the boy done told you I
come through in Folger whose abide to
run papers to get a paper cut these cats
talk about money but they don't make
enough to really he's starting and if
they did I bet they would buy it out but
it's nothing I'm coming out here I'm
puffing I'm blazing I'm archetype it's
amazing you know the copic is phasing
i'm the topic the pension the topic to
mention a trending topic i'm popping
they wanna talk it is crazy in chicago
be poppin leave him in the street a pool
of blood leaking to the sewer
I'll leave you wanted that on or if she
was your girl I better did it
if not and then young Richie that I had
in the fryer cuz you know that I be
waiting and trying to catch the nut sack
like Harry Potter Quidditch in the air
hoppip on the broomstick you know that I
do this off for the top I'm about to
lose it
you can check making some crazy and I
meant to asylum you know they can't face
me okay
cooker so I need to I'm all for the top
you know you hard I don't believe you do
softer than cardboard so why you acting
hard for I slow you off the starboard
side of the ship I'm riding this is you
know who it is I'm with my man beside me
gets him a sure as the blood your
girlfriend a passer to him a name to
chuck you know middle Smasher don't pass
my girlfriend that's not cool not checks
me I just sold I was freestyles like
[ __ ] kiddos day what is these days now
where'd that come from
that was crazy no how about the rap
can I get it louder in my phone's brocro
time say Chuck give us something man I I
got something
yeah huh when I write raps like raps
like rolling of grass drop that like
glass drop that bottle and crash like
splash
I caught it cold like dimetapp chill
with that book she trying to Tyler that
fool what you rhyming a fool trying
round with that I flew through it makes
you think I'm gonna drive it back
nah mommy let me plant in pit cliché
come on a couple posters I'm in a couple
pitches pat you on the head kid this is
grown folk business I sit your ass down
while I'm about to God there oh man
excited to shock English oh yeah Vicki
I'm so big as Vicki's oh no I'm not oh
nothing I'm just a nurse my knee in his
own right now go ahead man yeah brother
bunch of beer Gerlach out mentally push
to the steamer Polly's got prints to me
whipping the century of my crashing
passed instantly faith tragedy casually
actually after me past catastrophe
[ __ ] never had the audacity let mine
open sound like divine spoken rhymes bow
and hieroglyph type with this paper vez
save like catholics to the pocket i'm
stacking it saved money accountant count
him enough with the advocates with some
savages looking for the sun guy found
them got shine like the Sun guy kill him
and beat the charges like drunk cops
ride around in the school bus wrecking
balls on my lunch box I'm in a spot of
flashbacks for the young thoughts I've
seen him win the X's on their hands at
the show my man Astrid says she bad I
said don't go cuz if you do you're gonna
catch a case I did before you don't
wanna be there I'll tell them to take a
slow room
don't boom they'll just look at my son
that was very rare very bass yo set on
flashing baby thoracic plastic Internet